[Music]
let's dive in we can give this talk
about serverless ml solutions and here
on stage we have Vikram Tiwari
co-founder of Omni labs and we have
Martin here who is developer advocate at
Google cloud and to get started what is
Omni labs so only that's is a company
which is the startup based in San
Francisco we are building tools to
simplify and automate repeatable tasks
so repeatable tasks you can think of the
example that we're going to do today is
based upon analytics one of the
analytics arts that marketers do they
get data from various sources where ad
vendors where they run their campaigns
and they download those reports and they
have to get those into one central place
to take a look at the analytics of all
those reports that they're getting from
different ad vendors so few engineering
things that we keep on our side as ethos
of engineering team is keep everything
simple make things scale on demand and
use machine learning to augment the
users the users that we have of our
technology a machining tradition is more
than just building a model anyone can
build a model and we see so many of
those come up on github every day but
when we are talking about an end-to-end
solution it involves more than just the
model itself we have what amount of work
do you think you put into this sort of
data engineering versus building the
model you think the Chrome yeah actually
like building the model itself is really
easy because it's most of the time you
are just taking up paper that is
recently published cuz you want to
always be updated and then you cut it
down you take the mathematics that is in
the model to transform it to your Python
function or maybe if you are using Swift
or something else
yeah and convert that model converting
that model code it's not as actually
really hard it's mostly like getting
your data to work with that model mmm
which takes more time yeah yeah as we
are talking gonna be talking about here
today when you are building this
complete product it takes a lot more to
do that because you have to extract and
clean your data you have to do that over
time in a pipeline you have to do and
apply extra data transformations because
those are your new features that you
have to apply then you have to manage
this whole model pipeline that is there
so the configuration management of that
you doing using hyperbole ammeter tuning
and similar things and then your models
are not good enough unless they can
actually give value to the user so you
have to provide on-demand predictions to
the users right and this never stops
yeah you don't build a model and you're
done
yeah so a product is like it's not a
one-time proof-of-concept you have to
build the model and keep the machine
running and there's new data coming in
there's new machine learning models
getting out there and you have to
constantly give the value to the client
so for that this is the whole pipeline
this is not a one stop one way or one
process so there are a few engineering
challenges that we had to face we
categorized into four parts and that's
how we'll be walking today to that
presentation
so first is extracting and transforming
your data so extracting the data we are
doing this via API is from these vendors
these api's have limitations that you
cannot extract data all the time it's
not a socket based API or every vendor
will have different restrictions you
have to have quotas on those API and we
have to honor those quotas otherwise
it'll get blocked oh it sounds like that
might have happened in the past then all
the data that raw data that you get it
you have to also transform that data so
you have to transform the data for
multiple use cases cause analytics is
today's use case what's next machine
learning of course then once you have
all of this data you want to store that
in a central location where you can use
it for reporting as well as analytics
use cases and then you can store it all
for use cases of analytics but your
queries might become slow so you have to
make sure that your queries are always
performant and they should always be
running the results in a performant way
users don't want slow queries nobody
loves that and keep the cost low as well
so you don't want to scale up the
service we will talk more about that the
only labs is a start-up right yeah
you're looking at costs quite a bit
holiday and we'll see more about that
and how to manage costs and make this
all efficient yeah then once you have
all the data you have to actually build
your models and keep them updated
keeping the model updated is not just
keeping the model
good updated of course you have to
update your Python dependencies all the
time but you have to also make sure that
it's getting the new data there is
always our advertisers they are actually
running the campaigns every day so you
want to get all the data every day or as
much frequency as you can and generate
the newer model because your model is as
good as the data that is getting in
there then you also have to manage
retraining because there are new clients
that are coming in you want to use one
central model for all the clients or you
want to generate new models out of those
models the central model that you have
and of course hyper parameter tuning who
doesn't want to do that
you've never can build a good model by
yourself you have to use Hibernia tuning
to get the best hyper parameters and
finally all of this is no value unless
you can serve this in real time to your
clients so managing authentication which
client gets access to which model that
you have in-house depending on how much
they are paying and all of this managing
in real time predictions and this
traffic is very infrequent as we will
talk more in the talk more in the
presentation today excellent so with
this a lot of this can be done in server
less you've all heard we've all heard
about server less and server less
computing there's one part of server
list that gets most of the press
most of the blog posts most of the
attention and that is the central part
of the figure here the compute part so
server less computing just as a quick
recap in the Google cloud platform you
could do cloud functions if you have
just very simple pieces of code
functions you can string them together
or if you want to deploy something
bigger like a full application you would
run those on App Engine yesterday you
may have heard the announcement about
cloud run that is the third hexagon we
say there in the middle this is allows
you to upload deploy a container and run
that service Li
so surplice compute ok we can know what
that is but there's so much else so much
more to server less because we as
developers want to solve business
problems not engineering
so it that becomes a lot easier if we do
computation service Leslie but also if
we do data analytics database storage ml
develops messaging all these other
things can be done server Leslie as well
and we'll see some cases here where
Vikram will tell us how his startups
always start up Omni labs achieved
greater dev velocity by going server
less on some of these other pieces as
well not just compute so first we have
Vikram was mentioning extracting and
transforming the data so these data
pipelines as we heard they extract the
data from the API so they they clean it
merge it with other data and we we have
some engineering challenges here it's
not just a simple FTP importer
we are getting all this data from
different API so we have to clean it of
course there's which engineering that
you have to do and the biggest
challenges that we faced on our side was
the variability of the data size because
there could be a client which is running
a very small campaign so they are
getting ten entries a day versus there
could be a client which is running
thousands of campaign across geographies
and we are getting thousands of entries
per hour so data size varies for blind
to client plus frequency of data
injection could also vary there could be
somebody who's not running any campaigns
right now we don't want to keep machines
up for those injections or they could be
somebody who's running this and wants
this data every few hours and we want to
make sure that our solution can deliver
this to them so you couldn't have a sort
of one size fits all yes what made this
hard yeah yeah yeah so what we tried was
we tried to as soon as you have a data
problem first thing you do you write a
Python code what do you know what should
machine so we tried that but there were
multiple issues there what could happen
is we could allocate access compute so
if there was data size was really small
and we had given it a ten CPU machine
not really required sometimes it might
be release big data set and we didn't
allocate enough CPU or in a frame in
there and RAM is not compressible so
it crashes the whole machine that that
also happens sometimes this whole
process since it's happening in a chain
process joint chain manner first we get
the data on one machine then we
transform it on another machine then we
pass it forward to the third machine to
push it into different storage sections
this whole process is chained together
with different scripts and if one of
those breaks the whole system collapses
it's very brittle and the collapse is
all any tiny breaking causes cascading
collapses hmm so this is of course
managed VMs as we heard there is another
way to potentially doing this with cloud
dataflow you don't manage servers it can
take batch or streams of data and then
server lessly dynamically allocate these
jobs so across physical machines and you
don't really see the physical machines
or manage them much would that be
something to be useful from my labs yeah
so that's why actually we ended up doing
so we ended up utilizing data flow and
with data flow what we were able to do
is we were able to launch as many jobs
as we can in parallel so we split off
our jobs into smaller chunks as you can
see from the image we launched like 10
jobs within a minute and all of this run
jobs are running in parallel and if one
of those jobs fails it doesn't cause any
issues with another job that I write
that is running so other systems can
keep running and one individual jobs
fails by itself also all the machines
since there are pal they're scalable by
themselves say if your job runs in seven
minutes or seven days your machines can
keep alive system scheduler will take
care of that and they can scale up and
down as your data flow transformations
are happening you have jobs that run for
seven days whew and some more than that
that's a big job yeah yeah so we were
doing most of these as bad shots we have
started doing most of these now as a
streaming job so it's always running
machines there are some people who have
done this job whose machines have been
running for years now yeah so while
doing this we came into touch with
Apache beam Apache beam is the
programming model that you use to
transform your data and run this on a
dataflow pipeline Apache beam provides
you and out of box methods so that there
is reading from a file or splitting your
data into or creating a flat map plus
you can create your own functions and
apply those into the utilize those
custom functions as well the best thing
about Apache beam is your pipeline
options as you can see on the top if you
want to take it away from GCP you just
change your pipeline options and you are
on your local machines your another
cloud provider or anywhere else you want
to run it and it's just change of
configuration your code never changes
you would of course never want to take
it off of GCP but it's nice to have an
escape hatch yeah all right so yeah you
should never be a prisoner if your cloud
platform
wherever vendor you you're using keep is
keeping your data and code prisoner on
there
and it's probably not a place to be you
want to always be able to have this gate
but it's sort of like if you're on a
plane right you probably don't want to
use the escape X the emergency exits too
often but it's good to know that they
are there so the next step
Vikram was telling us about is filling
the data lake so data lake is this
pattern where you getting the data from
various resources like these API is
external API and instead of crunching it
as you're importing it you just store it
all in sort of raw form then when you
need to when you have certain data needs
or reports or machine learning that's
when you apply the transforms that means
that you can do things like I want to
have everything by week and grouped by
week or the next month you want
everything grouped by hour and you can
get that because you have all the raw
data now so the data lake is the central
source for all your or your raw data and
you saw some real challenges here with
filling
yeah yes well as I mentioned already
that there could be a thousands of
entries which could come in every are so
what you want is a really good injection
system which is right heavy and then you
also want to make sure that your
analytics can aggregate really quickly
because you are going to be doing a lot
of operations on different times and
different window options plus you also
want to be able to do modeling on top of
this data so you will have different
windows sessions could be really huge it
could be ears of data that you could be
using to do the modeling part so the
initial approach that we went with was
dump and pray so we took all the data
that we were getting in through our
pipelines and pushed all of that into
bigquery straight up and we demanded
bigquery to scale up cause bigquery
bigquery the issues that we faced in
there well anytime we had to update all
data it's a trouble there are update
operations in bigquery but you don't
really want to do those those are really
costly and limitations are there plus
every time we were querying the data you
were querying all of the data so the way
bigquery works is whenever you are
querying
a column it has to go through all of the
values in that column unless you limited
by our some certain limitations plus as
we are storing all of this data from
years worth of their campaigns
it keeps the storage costs keep getting
add up so we want to reduce that storage
cost as well so as you can see here a
query that run ran on a small table it
costs 32 MB to process that data so 32
megabytes here is data that is pulled in
yeah just because we are querying one of
the columns in there and you are not
perhaps not even using yeah only wanna
use like the first ten rows because I
want to only understand what happened in
the last are I don't need to get all the
data in there but there's no way to put
the limits around that right now so I
see and you typically you have time
series data yeah and you typically are
more interested in the newer data
generally yeah I don't want to see that
historical data unless they were doing a
meeting in yeah and sometimes I want to
see it all but most of the time just the
new stuff yeah so for that one there
there is a technique called date
partitioning so basically you have this
big more a big table but with within
bigquery you can tell bigquery to
partition on date for example and
internally bigquery service splits it up
into many small tables so you don't have
to query them all would that be a good
fit for Omni labs yeah
yeah so that's what we ended up doing we
ended up with the approach of divide and
conquer so we took our data as it was
coming in we split it into the date
chunks as it is coming in based upon the
date that we got the data we split it
and put it into that partition and using
that we could actually ingest a lot of
data even if it's a historical item
earlier we were like we don't want to
ingest all this data because it's going
to be costly now we could in this all
the data because bigquery allows you to
store all the data and if you're not
querying on that then reduce the pricing
for you.when who doesn't want that it's
an easy win plus now that I'm querying
on these partition tables I can very
easily limit those to a particular
vendor so as you can see in the query we
are partitioning it to just 2018 data
even if I'm querying two years of worth
of data
I've already reduced the size from 32
mb/s of query to 9.7 MB of query query
runs faster gives me the result faster
and the costs are cheap so I'm saving
not only in the storage I'm also saving
on the queries that I'm making and you
mentioned there was this older data is
cheaper to store yes yeah so after 30
days if I'm not getting the number we're
wrong if you don't access the data if
you don't update the data you can still
access the data data accessing the data
never gets like there's no latency
you won't see the latency there but it
just becomes cheaper since you're not
updating that data anymore oh that's
nice yeah
so we talked here about we heard about
partitioning by date putting limitations
on date there is of course this
general-purpose database that allows you
to do all that that is not bigquery so
there is just plain old sequel databases
you could run
and you can partition or you can put
limits on when you run queries on those
could you tell us a little bit about why
not going with the plane sequel solution
yeah so sequel solution would have been
perfect cause what you can do is next is
when you get the data and you see the
numbers are different you can just go
and update that number of value but
sequel solutions are really easy to get
set up but really hard to scale think of
right now I could have started with a
small sequel instance but as soon as I
get more data I need more disk space as
soon as I have more clients which are
querying I need to scale up my cluster
because I need more ram in there I need
more CPU when there are a lot of clients
doing this and they want to do this
frequently I want to add a caching layer
in the front of that and as client scale
on that you add a cluster in front of
that again so it's just chasing the
problem all the way down and you keep
scaling and it never stops with bigquery
push it all in there don't have to worry
about it ever again and sequel cloud
sequel is somewhat server fool yeah as
well yeah so it's like you have to still
do the capacity planning on your side
they can automatically do replication
they will do backups for you they will
manage it as a sequel database it's not
an analytics database you want to use
bigquery as the analytics database for
you what's nodes yeah and you said
Vikram that it's easy to get started
yeah so is this something that perhaps
when you start building a proof of
concept you might go with sequel
yeah and migrate to bigquery or yeah
your thoughts depending upon your needs
if if your needs are not really if you
see that your clients are not gonna be
is either not too many clients or it's
not going to be too many frequent
queries or not too many aggregations
sequel might be a perfect fit for you
and you might have to maybe go to two or
three tiers of scaling of your sequel
instances and you should do that it's
very easy to get started but bigquery is
also easy it's scales Oh excellent all
right those were two down two to go
the third item the the third engineering
challenge is keeping the machine
learning models fresh because as we
heard in in a in a machine learning lab
or in when you're testing it out you
might build a model and you're done
but in a real
company like Vikram's company these
models have to be refreshed all the time
for the new data that comes in so these
models must be updated all the time on
the latest data could you tell us some
about the challenges you run into when
updating yeah sure so think of like when
you build a machine learning model it
uses we used last year worth of data to
build that model now next day I'm
getting new data which is only 24 hours
of data but do not I want to make sure
that my model is fresh so I will have to
use this one year worth of data plus
this 24 hours of data merge together and
then retrain my whole model this works
but every few days you're gonna keep
increasing the size of your data so the
retraining part time will every few days
you will see it increasing and there's
no way around it or is it there is a way
so the we will talk about the way in a
minute another issue that we had was we
don't want to keep rebuilding these
models for every new client that we get
if all the clients that we are getting
are trying to do the same problem over
and over again you don't want to rebuild
the same model code and redeploy those
same pipelines all the time you want to
use the same version the same model
between that model and utilize that
model for all the clients if you can so
we want what we want to use is the
central model but retrain that or the
specific data for the client so our
initial approach was using ax she burst
at C boost allows us to build linear
models or random files type models and
you can very easily scale the parameters
in here so as we got more clients as we
got more different types of clients or
different types of options that they
wanted to include we built a lot of
models and the model size was increasing
so as we see here like initially we
started with on week 1 we have a smaller
model and week 2 we get model size keeps
getting prettier and data also keeps
getting bigger the compute time takes
getting bigger everything gets keeps
getting bigger and bigger model
retraining also takes a lot of time our
clients are not satisfied if you take
more than 24 hours just to give them a
real-time more predictions like on the
new data
plus we have to manually maintain the
whole model deployment lifecycle every
time we get a new model you have to make
sure that the older model gets phased
out you want to deallocate the resources
computer resources that are available
there maybe you want to keep them cause
maybe the new model doesn't work really
well and you want to really quickly
switch back to the older version as well
so there's a lot of toil that goes in
there and maintaining these models yeah
I guess you could theoretically end up
in a place where it takes more than 24
hours to process the last 24 hours
yeah that means you never catch up yeah
and it happens as soon as you have more
clients and a lot of data coming in and
you will face that phone that sounds
like it sounds like a good problem find
the problem yeah yeah so one one thing
to consider in this sort of situation is
tensorflow
running tensorflow on ml engine which is
server less you don't have to set up a
set of servers scales better you have
you get these sort of checkpoints and
API versioning that Vikram was just
talking about you get those built in so
you don't have to manually deal with
them and of course because it's server
less you can then focus on your models
and not ops is that something that would
fit for Omni labs yeah so we ended up
actually using tensorflow on machine
learning so rather than using extra
boost models we ended up moving all of
that to tends to flow with tensorflow it
provides you the ability to retrain your
models only on the new data we use
checkpointing with checkpointing you
train your model for the one year of
worth of data you create a checkpoint on
that time and next time when you are you
have to retrain your data your model
again today you get the new data start
from the checkpoint and you retrain your
model on that new data only training
time is much faster
the only time we have to take longer
time is when a new client comes on board
and we have to retrain the model on the
whole of their data then another problem
that we had retraining for all the
different clients now with tensorflow
there is a concept therein called
transfer learning so we built one big
model and anytime a new client comes in
we use transfer learning to transfer the
parameters and weights that we have
learned across our clients on to
specific based upon the needs and
constraints of a specific
client Biddy tray in that model and now
we have a new model and we can keep
training our global model and lower
split-off model for each client based
upon their own data plus we ended up
using wide and deep model for this we
all talk about that in a minute
the best point with this was we reduce
the cost so much that we don't really
see any increase happening it's always a
flat line and just this mean and that if
I come on as a new customer maybe I
don't have a whole lot of data I'm bring
it with me yeah you can still serve
decent predictions because you have a
good model for all your other clients
yeah so that this helps in new clients
as well because new clients haven't
tried all the geographies near clines
haven't tried all the different
parameters that you can run their
campaigns upon since we have seen this
across our clients we can't give them
optimizations and recommendations on how
to run their campaigns because we see a
full picture and we don't have to wait
for them to get their data we know their
constraints we can retrain the model
based upon their constraints so the more
clients you get the the smarter your
company becomes yeah feeds on data yeah
purchase cycle yeah yeah so I talked
about wide and deep models when we
started using moving away from tensor
flow moving from extra boost to tensor
flow we stumbled into this this was very
recent at that point in time wide models
are really good for memorizing stuff so
if you want to make sure that whenever
you are doing a targeting on a single
place you want to make sure when you are
targeting San Francisco you also get
Oakland in there so those models will be
really good at that because they
understand this whole thing is the Bay
Area deep models are really good at
generalizing so if you want to target
San Francisco
they might also suggest you that you
should try Austin and New York because
those are tech hubs and it has learned
that because because often those are
deep neural networks because of
generalization their ability to
generalize but what happens with deep
neural networks is those are not really
constrained specific you can't put some
constraints in there to say I actually
don't want to use this so an option is
if you want to get recommendations for
teenagers
you don't really want adult
recommendations in there you just want
it for teenagers so you want to put
those limitations in there for these
kind of problems that we have we have
similar problems for this we ended up
merging these two together this is not
our research resources by Google team we
used wide and deep models their papers
published for this and we do this whole
thing we could have written the whole
code from our side but tensorflow
provides an easy way to utilize wide and
deep models they have the fully featured
API all you have to do is connect your
data into it you can optimize and tell
it exactly which features or the cross
features that you want to utilize which
ones are the deep features that you want
to utilize you can put your constraints
in there plus you don't have to manage
how the data will get distributed how
the training will happen tensorflow will
take care of all of that if you put it
on machine learning engine it will take
care of scaling the machines for you and
you can do hyper parameter tuning as
well there so you get the best model by
you get the best model architecture by
using wide and deep and you get the best
model accuracy because of using hyper
parameter tuning on cloud normal engine
oh so it's kind of the best of both
worlds yeah we combine them yeah nice
all right
so all of this shuffling data around all
of this
tuning models all of this stuff accounts
for nothing if you don't actually are
able to make predictions in the end so
making predictions I understand that
this is something where you told me
customers come in on Monday morning they
all sit there they all hit the report
[Music]
challenge yeah so challenge that we face
is like nobody cares about their
campaigns on Friday
everybody wants the reports on Monday
morning and they want them all the
suggestions because they want to apply
all the solutions now so every more
every Monday in the morning we would see
a lot of traffic coming you couldn't
tell them that hey you guys you starting
like New York you can only start in the
morning they all wanted at one day
morning yeah everybody wants it in the
morning at the same time and that puts a
lot of load on your servers no matter
how much you scale and scaling come talk
about that ok so the approach that we
went up with okay if you are seeing more
traffic comment that
increase the machine size let's add more
machines into this cluster as we see
more and more users come in we kept
increasing those machines but it's not
really possible all the time because you
can't keep increasing the machines but
from Thursday to Sunday morning Sunday
evening nobody's using those nobody's
quitting on those so all the machines
that you have scaled up there you're
just paying I don't mind paying them but
please pay yeah what would happen the
one Monday morning no matter how much we
had scaled it up it would still go to a
hundred percent CPU because everybody's
trying to do it at the same time
everybody's squaring the servers and
machines would become unresponsive you
don't really want your scenes to go down
all the hard work that we did on getting
that data transforming it putting it in
everywhere building these machine
learning models all of that fails if you
are not able to serve your clients
properly so what would would actually
happen with the crash would they slow
down yeah like the first person who gets
to get there is that really quickly yeah
but after that slowly and gradually
start slowing down unless like we see it
and we increase the machines in the
cluster but it gradually slows down and
once the CP which is hundred percent it
just becomes unresponsive nobody's
getting any predictions today no yeah no
good okay so it sounds like a very
variable load here and a lot of systems
have that I mean most systems that all
of us build are probably very variable
not very many people hitting our stuff
at 3:00 a.m. all right but more people
hitting it say Monday morning so one
percent one possibility here is to let
Google handle the scaling up and down
with cloud functions cloud functions is
sort of a the gateway can be one of your
gateways into the Google cloud once you
the the user hits a cloud function
endpoint and HTTP you cannot code in
there that they can then hit cloud
storage machine learning BigTable all
these other products that are in the
cloud platform and that ingestion point
that that a cloud function is that
gateway into
GCP it scales up and also scales down so
you don't pay when people aren't using
it would that be a good fit for this
Monday morning yeah so without functions
there's no server management there's it
automatically scales up and down you
only pay only when you are running your
code and it runs in response of the
events that's the best part plus it
connects and extends to all of the
existing Google Cloud functions that we
have all the internal systems either is
machine learning engine or any other API
is that we have so that's what we ended
up doing our new approach was to go
serverless
we went with cloud functions error rate
and latency drop to almost zero it's
still an error because users are not
trying to they're trying to get
predictions on a very different data or
something that our model doesn't exist
even or a totally new client who wants
to get their predictions just right now
without even running any campaigns if
people do that so we were able to scale
up on Monday mornings as the load came
in it will automatically scale up and
whenever there is no more requests
coming in on Thursday on to Sunday it
will just scale down itself to guide
that code it's really simple actually
it's one single file that we use across
all of our clients what we do is
whenever a different client comes in all
of those model names and authentication
parameters along with the data that they
want to request to get predictions upon
all of those get passed into one single
endpoint and based upon that we make the
correct request to machine learning
engine to get the predictions and one
single point enables all of this scale
up and down we don't have to manage all
the code it's just one single place code
to manage we don't our handling you sit
in there because yeah so to rack up to
wrap up initially this was our approach
where we were hoping for no alerts you
can hope for that but you will still get
that as you can see our fill over
replica was also getting 100% in usage
in there you had a failover replica yeah
the failover was also given over yeah
you can never have too much computer
yeah yeah so we start
like we had compute engine for serving
instances we have compute for our
machine learning tasks we had compute
for our data ingestion tasks everywhere
it was compute engine but we moved from
there into a completely service solution
where we focused only upon what matters
for our business so clients now query to
come out loud functions
cloud functions get the data from get
the predictions from ml engine and on
the other side we query and get all the
raw data from external API using cloud
dataflow hosted - big bigquery and
Google storage cloud storage for machine
learning modeling tasks sorry yeah I was
gonna say use you make it sound very
easy yeah we used to do it this way and
hundred percent CPU and we just we
switched over I mean you're a smart guy
Vikram but this could you tell us a
little bit about your journey from the
server full world to the server less
world yeah so yes surveillance works
really well but the best thing to do
that you can do is trust the Google or
any other server solution but verify on
your end and no you don't need watching
so to do this the best way to get set up
is set up your monitoring and alerts you
want to make sure that your services are
up and you are constantly monitoring
like we did for bigquery we wanted to
monitor how our queries were doing so we
are looking at the latency for our
bigquery queries so monitoring and
alerts will make sure that your systems
are up and they are actually doing as
you would expect them to do but
sometimes you actually need a view into
the mesh into these systems it systems
of black boxes you can't really
SSH into these machines and tail the
logs so what you want to do is you want
to set up the systems in there so you
can actually get the logs in the real
time so we use stag driver logging which
enables us to get all the logs from all
these clusters that automatically scale
up and down you don't have to do
anything in there and it will just get
all these logs to this one central
platform for logging and there you must
write the good code but I don't so we
still need other tracking in there cause
there are some exceptions that only
happen on server in production so for
that we ended up using
tracking so any exceptions that we are
not catching there are a lot of times
that you deploy something in the real
time and you make mistakes so make sure
that there is something that can catch
those exceptions and rather than failing
abruptly you feel gracefully and these
you drawers Jerusem blue hexagons here
let's just make sure I understood the
first one for monitoring and alerts that
was stackdriver staggered our money it's
like we're monitoring yeah and for
logging it was I have a guess what the
last one is called so the cool things
with with these is that they are all
server lists you don't have set up
servers that manage the monitoring and
logging and error tracking if you have a
Google cloud platform project today you
can just click on the hamburger menu up
on the left and turn on these services
in your account and but but you did so
you you set all of this up this took
some time yeah is it's not a turnkey
solution it takes time to like rewrite
your code from Python to Apache beam and
using a big node.js project to one
single function to do all these
predictions it took some time and like
adding all these features in there so it
this is a multi-year journey that we
took from like almost a year and to end
to build all these solutions and run
it's totally serverless yeah all right
very good
should we do the last slide let's do it
let's do it should you right-click you
clicked yes excellent so this business
problems
[Applause]
[Music]